salut c'est jimmy j'espère que vous
allez bien je suis ravi de retrouver
pour confiner d'ici et d'ailleurs dans
cette émission on part la rencontre des
martin kia qui vivent un peu partout
dans le monde et aujourd'hui je vous
emmène chez quelqu'un que vous
connaissez forcément il s'agit de morale
voyez salut maurane comment tu vas on
voulait prendre de tes nouvelles
d'ailleurs merci de nous accueillir chez
toi on est où exactement on en profite
pour vaincre les mets un petit peu bon
ben ça va c'est bien rangé c'est donc à
paris où tu vis depuis un petit moment
déjà comment ça se passe au confinement
pour toi c'est tranquille c'est selon
qui les attentions précaution on sait
que j'approuve et le tour est joué
je suis ferme et 24 sur 24 ça c'est cool
mais voilà depuis les gens sont habitués
et d'après les petits millions que je
n'étais pas tout seul en plus ce qu'il
semblerait que tu partages ton
confinement avec deux copines
ouais je suis avec les amis du coup
c'est un cul mais nous saluons s'occuper
la musique aucune vérité est beaucoup
plus évident de le vivre à plusieurs
voitures par les musiques maurane ça
fait un an qu'on attend ton album alors
j'imagine que si tu prends le temps
c'est parce que tu travailles dessus
pour que ce soit super bon en plus y'a
énormément d'attentes concernant fait
cet album on adore ce que tu fais où ça
on et j'appelle quasiment tous les
thèmes chers à distance
on essaie aussi de voir ce qu'on change
dans la stratégie puisque bondues
quoique continuellement les choses sont
différentes
et voilà on n'a toujours pas de projet
de me sentir avant parce que c'est prévu
pour mai à la base cette affaire pour
mai
je vois là j'ai trop être parce que j'ai
fait j'ai je pense que je vais
surprendre et puis en fait j'y suis
resté fidèle à moi même mais ça ne sent
pas bon c'est parce que j'ai eu
l'occasion de voyager trop être qu'ils
en profitent aussi pour permettre
d'éventuelles clip qu'on va pouvoir
faire après le mouvement s comptait pas
aussi des courts pendant la gauche où on
me débrouillais on est permanent
continue à travailler
tu as sorti d'ailleurs il ya quelques
temps quelques jours à peine
un clip qui a été tourné avant
confinement j'imagine ouais je vais
tourner en janvier c'est le clip de
l'insomnie des albums le super gai ouais
évoquera télé sur le tournage fonds dont
c'était cette règle et on l'a fait en
bresse avec l'ip je suis très bien de
cette fille là parce que c'est fait il
va tomber trois jours d'ailleurs
puisqu'on parle de joël il a sorti il ya
quelques jours à projet musical en plein
confinement c'était une belle surprise
d'ailleurs il a il a composé une musique
à la guitare il envoyait une vingtaine
d'artistes à peu près il leur a demandé
de poser de susciter des chanteurs des
musiciens ça donnait quelque chose de
2,2 magnifique tu fais partie de ceux
qui ont travaillé sur ce projet là ouais
c'était g
j'ai quand même fait un tour des gestes
soient super bon genre n'a pas dit à
l'envoyé ça après qu'une sortie est
génial j'ai été douchés parce que les
univers se marrer super bien même si on
n'est pas tout seul dans l'année dans le
même style à la dass et franchement
quand j'ai entendu et complète elle a
levé la voix des jeunes c'est une
expérience musicale
voilà trop le calme en enfer comme ça en
fait qu'est ce qui te manque le plus en
ce moment maurane ces bêtes qu'on allait
créer plein de tournage et que je le
prends dans mes deux mois les goûts ça
fait un petit personnel en même temps
c'est quoi le haut mais on reste chez
soi qu'on se protège pour l accession
l'après contaminer les autres et tout on
ne sait pas je ne voudrais pas parce que
c'est un confinement grande roue on est
vraiment on était content en tout cas de
prendre de tes nouvelles
on va juste donner tes réseaux sociaux
parce que tu es très très actif sur les
réseaux sociaux tu gardes le contact
avec les gens qui t'aiment qui aime ta
musique
on va rappeler à ceux qui y keane ne
suis-je pas encore où ils peuvent le
faire
oui aussi montrer que c'est noël etc
on va tester et si je voulais finir à
tous de rester chez son psy parce que
plus vite
super merci beaucoup maurane en tout cas
on était ravi de voir que tout va bien
pour toi tu saluera merrill bien
évidemment pour nous
on espère que ça va pour elle également
prenez soin de vous surtout et puis on
se voit très très bientôt avec je
l'espère cet album sur le calcul beauvau
studieusement pendant ce confinement
merci maurane et à très vite s'était
confiné d'ici et d'ailleurs on se
retrouve très vite et en martinique la
première à la rencontre d'un autre
martiniquais quelque part dans le monde
a très vite
[Musique]